[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lors du 7-8 journal sur
tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 24 avril tout
de suite les titres de cette édition la
suite de notre dossier sur mai 68 à
l'occasion des 50 ans du mouvement après
le souvenir des acteurs de la
mobilisation entretien ce soir avec
l'yvelinois gérard larcher le président
du sénat revient sur son soutien à
l'époque au général de gaulle alors sous
le feu de la contestation sociale
l'agriculture autrement c'est la
conviction de cet homme le portrait de
la semaine est consacrée à et vexant
saut depuis à 15 ans il s'est lancé dans
un élevage plus respectueux des animaux
l'exploitant nous a ouvert les portes de
sa ferme à auffargis souhaite utiliser
la musique classique comme anti stress
des bêtes
enfin les beaux jours et la réouverture
de la cueillette l'activité a repris
depuis quelques semaines à la ferme de
viltain à jouy en josas et les visiteurs
peuvent ramasser fruits légumes et
fleurs notamment les tulipes qui sont en
ce moment prises et reportages invités à
suivre dans ce journal véronique chaplin
fondatrice du tiebreak le trophée de
golf au profit de l'association sos
gazelle fête cette année ses 26 ans
c'est devenu une habitude désormais 1
dans le set 8 journal on débute par un
point transports la fin du de la
cinquième phase du mouvement perlé des
cheminots après deux jours de débrayage
le trafic doit reprendre progressivement
en demain à partir de 8 heures
il faut tu veux il faut tout de même du
temps pour un retour définitif à la
normale avec quelques perturbations donc
encore pour le réseau qui passe par
saint quentin en yvelines
demain prévoir sur le rer c et trois
trains sur quatre sur la ligne l du
transilien ses 9 points 9 trains sur 10
en revanche pour la ligne u le trafic
sera normal
vous pouvez rester informé sur le site
transilien.com à suivre dans cette
édition l'entretien avec gérard larcher
mais d'abord direction en bennes ou une
cérémonie a marqué la fin de stage des
tout premiers cadets de la gendarmerie
ils sont issus du lycée blériot de
trappes et celui du vexin achard dans le
val d'oise et mickaël landreau a suivi
cet événement une première en ile de
france ce vendredi 20 avril une
cérémonie a été organisée sur le camp de
ben pour récompenser la fin de stage de
là pour
mir promotion des cadets de la
gendarmerie de la région parisienne
c'est un symbole les cérémonies
militaires sont ont une portée
symbolique pour marquer leur intégration
et leur appartenance à la grande famille
à la grande communauté gendarmerie cette
année quinze lycéens âgés de 17 à 21 ans
ont intégré cette filière d'excellence
ils ont reçu leur diplôme devant leurs
proches ça fait plaisir de rendre fiers
nous nos aînés nos parents notre famille
nos cadres sa tête et dire les futures
générations ainsi engagé aussi ce serait
un très bon entraîneur pour les soutenir
l'ex boxeur jean marc mormeck est
actuellement délégué interministériel à
l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer s'est rendu sur place en
tant que parrain de la promotion
moi je suis très content de voir cette
jeunesse on en parle positivement
aujourd'hui qui font des choses et on
parle beaucoup de deux jeunes qui font
des choses négatives mais aussi vous
parler des jeunes qui s'investissent et
qui veulent faire les choses prochaine
étape pour les lycéens de la promotion
le baccalauréat dans quelques semaines
une fois leur diplôme obtenu les
intégrerons pour la plupart la
gendarmerie
cette année ce sont les 50 ans de mai 68
nous poursuivons notre série pour
découvrir le souvenir laissé par le
mouvement aux yvelinois interview
exclusive ce soir avec gérard larcher le
président du sénat se confie sur son
soutien apporté à la politique du
général de gaulle il se souvient
notamment de certaines tensions
à l'époque avec des étudiants mobilisés
contre la politique du président de la
république la première partie de cet
entretien réalisé par nicolas landry
marion ptac et mickaël medoro aux cadres
à gérard larcher bonjour bonjour alors
je rappelle que vous êtes le deuxième
personnage de l'état et que vous êtes un
gaulliste assumer au mois de mai 1968
vous aviez dix neuf ans et vous étiez
engagé depuis 1966 chez les jeunes
gaullistes au moment de ces
mobilisations étudiants qui ont éclaté
en 1968 comment vous percevez ces
événements d'abord je suis engagé c'est
vrai chez les jeunes gaullistes et ma
première réaction c'est dire mais qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent chez gauchistes
en même temps je perçois qui a là un
mouvement de société et en même temps si
leur chèque de très nombreux jeunes
engagés engagé politiquement engagé
syndicalement engagé aussi dans la vie
des aumôneries ou spirituelle et cette
réalité là fait que nous sommes assez
nombreux et j'allais dire à avoir une
appartenance politique
en tous les cas des références
politiques j'ai le souvenir de copains
plutôt à gauche d'autres plutôt à droite
de centristes et cet engagement s'est
pas uniquement un ou deux dans une
classe de 1ère ou dans une classe de
terminale et donc pour moi je vis 68
engagé comme jeune gaulliste et comme je
ne lis qui entend soutenir l'action du
général de gaulle mais qui en même temps
mesure que cet engagement est aussi le
questionnement le questionnement de la
société de 68 après une période
extraordinaire
j'allais dire de croissance nous
n'avions aucun problème pour trouver un
emploi à la sortie de nos études nous
avions plutôt le sentiment qu'on vivait
de mieux en mieux chaque année mais en
même temps peut-être que notre
génération avait aussi d'interrogations
quelle sera ma place dans les décisions
de la société
or je rappelle que le général de gaulle
est au pouvoir depuis dix ans puisqu'il
accède au pouvoir en 1958
vous dites qu'il y avait un certain
questionnement sur quoi ça repose s
élabore le général de gaulle chez c'est
pas dix ans de pouvoir ces essais c'est
une épopée
c'est dans l'imaginaire d'un jeune comme
moi qui a va avoir dix neuf ans c'est
l'homme qui a redonné à la france son
honneur je vis en normandie dans des
villes qui sont reconstruction après les
bombardements et ça m'a marqué moi même
je suis un enfant qui se voit intégrer
une maison reconstruite après les
bombardements de maison qui est affecté
à ses parents et donc cette maison
quelque part les le symbole du renouveau
de notre pays et on le doit en général
de gaulle alors bien sûr il ya dix ans
de cinquième république
on a presque oublié que la génération
précédente elle partait faire la guerre
en algérie
on a le sentiment d'entrer dans une
société de consommation et en même temps
la préoccupation de ne pas simplement
des consommateurs on a me semble-t-il le
désir ou qu'on soit sur les chevaux
politique ou syndical on a envie des
facteurs et quand vous voyez que le
gouvernement ordonne peut être une
répression sur ces jeunes qui
manifestent qui ont quasiment votre âge
quelle réaction vous avez d'abord les
jeux des îles ont pas j'allais dire à
moitié moi j'ai des souvenirs très
précis puisque je suis en classe
préparatoire vétérinaire voilà que des
jeunes veulent m'empêcher de passer le
concours vétérinaire et je vous cache
pas j'ai pas fait le coup de poing mais
quand même pas loin en même temps
j'étais engagé puisque je représentais
les classes préparatoires au conseil
d'administration riez je n'étais pas
passifs et le jeune engagé que je suis
décidé qu on a le droit de passer ses
examens décide d'aller dialoguer
dialoguer cette amo atténuée après cinq
décennies d'aller débattre avec un
certain nombre de ces jeunes
en même temps nous assistons à la
paralysie progressive du pays parce que
il ya toute la dimension sciences
sociales et cette dimension sociale en
même temps la répression
mai 68 y a pas un seul mort à méditer
sur la manière dont d'ailleurs le
pouvoir a conduit alors qu'il y avait
des manifestations
une manifestation et 2 millions de
manifestants
jal et envir justement parce que vous
parlez du mouvement social derrière
c'est les ouvriers qui vont manifester
vers le 13 mai il commence à dessiner
des à montrer leurs revendications
salariales notamment
quel regard vous portiez à 7 à ce moment
là sur la politique notamment
économiques
le nez par le gouvernement qui donne au
sol dans le plein emploi mais il ya
désir de modernisation je crois des
relations sociales
il ya un désir de mieux partager les
fruits du développement
d'ailleurs c'est une partie du projet du
général de gaulle qui n'a jamais
vraiment aboutie qui est l'intéressement
et la participation dans le projet
gaulliste qui vaut d'ailleurs mon
engagement
comme gaulliste social c'est de dire il
y a qu une seule économie qui fonctionne
on lui donne pas encore ce nom à ce
moment là c'est l'économie de marché
l'économie libérale mais elle doit être
tempérée tempéré à la fois par une
politique sociale mais aussi par la
participation de chacun au développement
de son entreprise de son activité et au
partage des fruits de la croissance
et ça je le comprends c'est bien et il
faut le dire le président profite d'eau
pour laquelle j'ai un immense respect il
n'est pas très favorable à
l'intéressement et à la participation
est d'ailleurs les les jeunes gaullistes
l'union des jeunes pour le progrès parce
que c'est autour de cette sensibilité là
que nous nous retrouvons con que nous
soyons carte ou pas en kart c'est pas le
sujet ils ont envie d'aller plus loin
dans la dimension sociale à la fois ils
s'opposent aux étudiants gaucho souvenez
vous il était bao certains étaient
encore nés aux staliniens et pour nous
c'était inacceptable
ont traité ce qu'on qualifiait d extrême
droite mais étaient dans une nostalgie
de l'algérie française
je dis ça parce que au classement
automatiquement extrême droite c c'est
une nostalgie et nous ont dit le général
de gaulle up bien conduit la
décolonisation il a redonné l'honneur à
notre pays
il a proposé le développement et c'est
vrai que la société s'interroge un an
avant le général de gaulle accepte la
proposition de loi de lucien de hoerdt
la régulation savez luciano g l'honneur
ou siéger avec lui bien après on
l'appelait le père la pilule mais c'est
une révolution culturelle
il faut bien le mesurer et le général de
gaulle l'a acceptée tu es sans doute pas
dans sa pensée de base et on sent une
société qui veut évoluer
suite et fin de cet entretien avec
gérard larcher demain mercredi dans le
7-8 journal c'est un éleveur pas tout à
fait comme les autres depuis 15 ans
erich samson pratiquent une agriculture
respectueuse de l'environnement et de
ses animaux élevage de races bovines
harare de bêtes qui paissent dans des
prairies sans pesticides il nous a
ouvert ses portes pour nous montrer son
exploitation c'est notre portrait de la
semaine
signés camille lambert
comme on peut l'entendre on est sûr sur
radio classique non pelées vaches toute
la journée ont la chance d'écouter les
plus grands compositeurs saônoise aubrac
island décosse vivent en harmonie bercé
par les notes des plus grandes pièces de
musique classique
aujourd'hui éric samson doit boucler un
veau né ce matin avec l'aide de ses
employés thomas et maxime octavia
rejoint officiellement le troupeau de
150 têtes
voilà c'est fini c'est fini ce film ao
oui en fait pour un joli conte un
contre-feu d'un ancien cavalier
international eric s'est reconverti dans
l'élevage il ya 15 ans dans sa ferme de
150 ha ha auffargis cohabitent chevaux
bovins poule et même des abeilles
grâce à un partenariat avec un
hypermarché de rambouillet il élève
aussi des aurochs vaches préhistorique
quasiment disparu une passion des
animaux et de leur bien-être
la relation avec les avec les animaux
c'est primordial ils ont malheureusement
pour beaucoup des dix courtes mais je
veux leur assurer la meilleure vie
possible dans les meilleures conditions
à la maison avec this fait mieux en
termes de qualité
nutritive en termes de bien-être animal
et ce jusqu'au bout je milite je suis
membre de la fad l'association en faveur
de l'abattage des animaux dans la
dignité
abattage sans souffrance et sans stress
foin à volonté et prairies sans
pesticides des terres sèches et sans vie
dans les années 90 en cause
l'utilisation massive de produits
chimiques
désormais elles servent à nourrir les
animaux de manière totalement naturelle
eric s'assure qu'elles sont prêtes pour
les beaux jours il y manque il manque un
peu de traces dans cette parcelle pour
avoir avec laurent pour réensemencer un
petit peu on fait du sur semi a jamais
on retourne la terre ont fait que du
sursaut me mets en mettra un petit peu
de trèfle violet trèfle blanc je
regarderai pour remettre quelques
légumineuses
plus on va mettre de variétés d'herbes
plus ont redonné le goût à la viande un
savoir faire et une qualité qui ont
séduit les plus grands chefs du trianon
palace à versailles à l'abbaye des vaux
de cernay en passant par paris mais
fervent défenseur du local il veille
aussi à fournir les restaurateurs
voisins en cuisine christophe cornier
maître restaurateur de l'auberge l'élan
travail s'est produit depuis une
douzaine d'années
on a sympathisé on à échanger et puis
après voilà on a découvert
ce qui faisait ses convictions voilà
comme nous aussi on est des gens de
conviction donc le courant est bien
passé
des convictions qui eric souhaite
partager au plus grand nombre avec sa
ferme modèle il espère montrer qu'une
autre agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et des animaux est
possible ma business model il est
complètement abouti parce qu'on a pas
d'un prends parce que les bêtes sont
nourries uniquement au point et à
l'herbe
donc on n'a pas les dépenses que peuvent
avoir les structures classiques il ya
moyen de faire mieux avec des animaux en
meilleure santé avec des animaux qui
s'exprime avec vraiment du vivant en
redonnant du vivant la terre pour rendre
ses produits accessibles
eric a ouvert une boutique gourmande il
ya un an favoriser le local et la
qualité une tendance sociétale
selon une étude réalisée par
l'observatoire de la consommation
responsable
86% des français estiment que consommer
local est une priorité
le sport une star de la nba dont les
yvelines le basketteur evan fournier
était à carrières sous poissy
aujourd'hui mardi l'international
français joueurs du orlando magic est
venu inaugurer le nouveau ou death
corner c'est le premier équipement de ce
type dans les yvelines
en plus des terrains de football et des
cours de padel déjà existants deux mini
terrain de basket indoor à trois contre
trois des conditions idéales pour
débuter le basket selon evan fournier
propos recueillis par marion ptac et
michael et demi d'euros quand tu es
gamin tu as vraiment de choix soit je
vais en club soit joué sur les plus
grandes et donc voilà ça c'est une
alternative peu différente et
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai mal au
genou maintenance parce que je veux sur
les plus grandes ce match allait c'est
donc si l'abonné ce genre de terrain je
regarderai la ses dimensions et un
billet sur la largeur c'est dire que là
en fait séparément un terrain c'est plus
de 2000 terrain mais en termes de
largeur de ligne de trois points de sa
cessé dimanche une grande journée autour
du golfe qui réunit chaque année et
chaque année des champions et anciennes
gloires du sport la 27e édition du
tiebreak roland garros elle se tient le
22 mai prochain c'est au golf de la
vaucouleurs à sivry la forêt un
événement au profit de l'association sos
gazelle avec moi plateau pour en parler
à sa présidente c'est véronique chaplin
bonsoir non ça c'est vous qui avez donc
fondé ce concept du tibre est qu'il y à
26 ans alors présentons d'abord
l'association sos gazelle elle oeuvre
pour l'éducation des enfants par la
santé le sport
oui tout à fait en fait moi j'ai
toujours eu la chance de travailler dans
le milieu sportif et moi-même jeune je
me suis rendu compte que le sport était
très rassembleur et
j'ai voulu avec tous les sportifs qui
m'encadrent donner la chance à un
maximum d'enfants de pouvoir pratiquer
le sport dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et également de créer des
centres d'accueil où ils pourront pas
pratiquer leur passion mais aussi être
encadrés aussi bien sur le plan scolaire
avec du soutien scolaire et sur le plan
santé ce qui est très important pour
être en bonne santé il faut ces trois
mètres thématique bon ensemble le sport
l'éducation la santé ces trois
thématiques qui vont ensemble mais je
pense que voilà c'est comme la vie c'est
une harmonie est effectivement pour être
en bonne santé faut pratiquer du sport
mais également pour bien pratiquer le
sport il faut être en bonne santé donc
c'est pour ça qu'il est important que
les trois soient réunies elle souhaite
gaz elle agit en afrique et aussi en
france
oui tout à fait alors en fait on sait
qu'une association avec 100% de
bénévoles qui agit un petit peu dans le
monde entier mais nous sommes
actuellement focus sur l'afrique avec
notamment le maroc et le sénégal et en
france en ile de france avec des jeunes
de la clinique de parly 2 et du carré
médical de versailles
racontez nous un peu l'histoire du
tiebreak vous avez lancé donc ça il ya
26 ans des grands noms qui sont présents
chaque année on peut citer laurent blanc
yannick noah souleymane mbaye pour ne
citer qu'eux il y en a il y en a plein
encore comment vous avez eu l'idée
de lancer ce concept et comment vous
avez aussi réussi à fédérer autour de
vous tous ces champions alors en fait
moi personnellement je démarrais ma
carrière chez nike et je trouvais qu'il
y avait beaucoup de différences de
traitement entre des grands champions
par exemple à l'époque agassi ou les
footballeurs que j'adore et d'autres
grands champions qui humainement avait
beaucoup de choses à apporter mais qui
n'était pas médiatique parce que leur
sport les témoins et donc je me suis dit
il faut que je crée sur terrain neutre
un événement qui rassemblerait des
sportifs de toutes les disciplines et
faire émerger des disciplines qui sont
moins connus et mettre tout le monde à
égalité alors ce 27e tiebreak roland
garros je le rappelle c'est le 22 mai au
golf de vos couleurs de la vaucouleurs
la journée s'organise autour de
plusieurs animations il ya bien sûr ce
trophée de golf qui réunissait ses
champions mais aussi des ateliers qui
sont proposées lors de cette journée
voilà alors au départ effectivement on
est sur un goal parce que c'est un sport
que tous les sportifs même en activité
peuvent pratiquer ils en ont le droit
déjà épuisés et c'est une mise au vert
c'est un sport on voit beaucoup de
champions qui se mettent au golf en fin
de carrière et qui ont cet esprit de
compétition terrible et le titre de
champion des champions ils se bagarrent
mais à côté de ça nous avons également
des champions qui encadre des jeunes et
nous avons des ateliers multisports donc
cette année il y aura de la boxe y aura
du foot ura du tennis et ce qui est mis
en valeur avec un anneau par un philippe
candeloro c'est les sports de glace
olympique voilà et est donc tout ce beau
monde rassemble entre 50 et 60 pour type
de haut niveau et 200 jeunes notamment
des yvelines de trappes et de versailles
clou de la journée c'est cette une
soirée enchères vous êtes venu avec
plusieurs objets qui seront mis aux
enchères ce soir là des maillots on peut
voir un gant une raquette
voilà plusieurs objets qui seront mises
aux enchères au profit de l'association
voilà alors en fait tous les ans et
c'est très amusant parce que les
sportifs se met en scène montre leur
objet 100 % des dons sont reversés
immédiatement à l'association pour les
jeunes et l'ours qui est important ce
sont les signatures bien
aman que vous pouvez voir la maillot de
marco garatti joueur du psg voilà la
quête de notre vainqueur de roland
garros où vous reconnaissez la signature
de yannick noah
les fameux gant de notre double champion
du monde souligne mme mbaye et puis des
petits objets et le t-shirt fétiche
voilà qui sera porté par les champions
et par les jeunes
c'est facile de solliciter les champions
ils répondent présents chaque année pour
même donné des objets alors moi je
dirais que la vie c'est un équilibre et
c'est du donnant donnant s'ils viennent
c'est parce que j'entretiens des
relations amicales et professionnelles
tout au long de l'année
j'ai la chance de deux vis de ma passion
je suis du coaching mental et donc nous
sommes amenés tout au long de l'année à
se côtoyer et donc c'est bon le tiebreak
c'est sur une journée mais tout au long
de l'année il ya une histoire il ya un
fil rouge
on se voit également en dehors on
prépare l'association ils sont venus
avec moi au sénégal ils sont venus au
maroc
donc il ya des liens de fraternité qui
se crée ils savent que c'est un rendez
vous important parce que c'est eux qui
font l'image c'est grâce à eux que vous
intéressait aussi à nous et je remercie
les médias je remercie également les
partenaires sans qui on ne pourrait rien
faire et donc ces sportifs saab la
valeur d'objets comme ça et donc ils
prennent la peine
ils prennent le temps ils se déplacent
et en plus ils le font avec beaucoup de
joie beaucoup de bonne humeur beaucoup
de disponibilité et j'en suis très
reconnaissante et je profite de ce
plateau pour pour les remercier et c'est
moi qui vous remercie avéré que chaplin
merci d'avoir été avec nous présidente
donc de sos gazelle organisatrice de ce
type break et je rappelle que le 27e
tiebreak roland garros se déroule mardi
22 mai au golf de la vaucouleurs et
c'est à sivry est la forêt ahmed el
moussaoui parrain du premier lady
bootcamp il s'est tenu le week-end
dernier au sdfc elle center à maurepas
le boxeur de la verrière classé au 19e
rang mondial a animé cette journée est
dédiée aux femmes elles sont venues de
toute la france et ont disputé par
équipe de 6 une série d'épreuves mêlant
effort technique force mentale et sens
du collectif
un rendez-vous pour encourager la
pratique sportive féminine est le rire
c'est un bon moyen de rassembler ce
week-end l'association trappistes tout
pour réussir lancé la première
de son festival du rire une dizaine
d'artistes amateurs et confirmés a
répondu présent retour sur ce rendez
vous avec mélanie poquet et nicolas
dandois déjà on va voir si son show pour
la danse et de lumière la vie de ma mère
roy ils sont trappistes yvelinois
franciliens leur mot de ralliement ce
samedi c'était le rire rire de tout et
de tout le monde rires de la société de
la famille des amis
photo cl l'humour ça donne de la joie
surtout belges ont ils ont un quotidien
pas semble difficile de nous que nous
arriver et que quand on sort d'un bon
spectacle en et gourdon sur la scène de
la salle jean baptiste clément des
comédiens mais aussi des chanteurs des
danseurs des hypnotiseurs on attrape et
de 2 c ça fait partie de ma ville je
vois là quoi c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté ça et puis pour que
tout mon courage pour voir ce qu'il ya
des arguments là il ya des artistes qui
peuvent sortir de ce secteur un peu plus
reculé que par les mêmes et pour que les
jeunes puissent s'amuser valoriser en
fait les talons des jeunes comme
l'égérie souvent oubliée au stigmatiser
ces artistes amateurs ou confirmés
participe au premier festival du rire un
festival pensé par tous pour réussir une
association trappistes nés en 2009
ces plateaux de ce festival la va
essayer de réunir un petit peu tous les
squares de trappes qui sont un petit peu
ta vie individuelle tout ça qu'on se
réunisse tous ensemble pour essayer de
partager un bon moment avec les
humoristes
comment y participer une dizaine
d'artistes a répondu présent pour cette
première édition l'association espère
rendre son rendez vous annuel pour
refermer ce journal un sujet qui sent
bon le soleil depuis le 7 avril la ferme
de viltain à jouy en josas a rouvert sa
cueillette possibilité pour les
personnes de venir ramasser des légumes
des fruits ou même des fleurs et avec le
retour du soleil les visiteurs en
profitent pour récolter des tulipes
parmi les adeptes nicolas landry la voix
est signée mélanie poker jaune ou rouge
violette ou bicolores un véritable
arc-en-ciel de tulipes avec des formes
différentes et des tiges plus ou moins
longue
les visiteurs de la cueillette ont le
choix entre les 53 20 il était proposé
par la ferme de viltain j'ai pris toutes
sortes de variétés différentes de
tulipes il ya un grand choix de couleurs
et comme je suis une habituée de la
ferme de viltain je sais que
généralement les bulbes sont de grande
qualité donc les fleurs durent longtemps
bah les tulipes oui c'est revenu pas
forcément pour ça mais
là cette saison et puis c'est sympa et
puis et puis ça va ça va égayer un peu
notre intérieur on sort de morosité de
l'hiver les couleurs parce qu'ils sont
jolis valeur sur les tulipes blanches où
les reines de la nuit
certaines se démarquent par leur forme
et leur nom la variété perroquet qui une
fleur avec voyez un mouvement dans dans
les pétales et dentelées alors des
tulipes ça se conserve à peu près entre
cinq et dix jours en fonction de la
température que vous avez dans votre
pièce ce qui est peut être une bonne
idée c'est le soir de les remettre dans
soit carrément dehors ou dans une pièce
plus fraîches la cueillette des tulipes
se poursuit jusqu'à la fin du mois
prochaine fleurs apparaître sur les
parcelles de la ferme de viltain les
roses au mois de mai et les lys en juin
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal très
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]